mi sono vestito elegante per l'occasione
il primo video avuto un successo
clamoroso
parlo della reaction sul tape op quindi
facciamo la reactions hulk e hip hop
number two se un ascolta bene imposto
dai cantoni coreani coi sottotitoli si
accorge che il vero significato del che
hip hop la partenza fantastica già una
cosa hai detto già siamo usciti dal
family friendly una cosa va bene andiamo
avanti
aridaje meglio anche il pony cosa la
morte sia kimi che questo fosse uscito
un dato nulla
[Musica]
cosa ho sentito
sembra che dicano esattamente così c'è
questa incredibile
dal nulla
[Musica]
anch'io
come fa macchiarti di di cavolfiore sono
pazzo pongono come livelli struzzo non
ti obbliga nessuno tranquillo qualcuno
ha mai provato a fumare il suo bar
ho capito
ma che posso
liz dell'erba fumi ciobar fumi quello
deciditi uno dei dopo e fa tutti e due
va bene ragazzi questa l'assaggino di
oggi mi dispiace che avevano del panico
nel toccarsi però l'ex giallorosso
ringraziamo la prossima four minutes
canzone in realtà si chiama mie emozioni
col calcio la son partiti carichi è
ragazzo confronto mazza e nokia non so
come si può arrivare a parlare del
calcio
[Musica]
il muto mi ha perso il phon
roselle montò di vai che parte il drop
rega voglio emozionarmi col calcio
[Musica]
emozioni col calcio ma no direi di no
e va bene
stiamo calmi e che si è rotto come dico
io e dice esattamente quello
[Musica]
tu che hai e s tutto come dico io tu
chiacchiere ok a faccio un grassi uno
starnuto va bene ok mi sono emozionato
con il calcio però almeno quando va bene
andiamo avanti per favore sarà che non
traggo ecco tu dovevi ascoltare e rutto
della tipa di prima che cantava questo
rally ha posto però vabbè sentiamo il
perché non cagà
[Musica]
scesi
e se bay milly quarti e grazie al cast
di cagli
[Musica]
ma poveri
quanto preso bene
è fantastico la balbuzie meraviglioso
non trovo il make up sia venom
idoneamente i sottotitoli dei tacchi che
fanno tac tac prove già come partita sta
canzone si immagina al meglio argan
ma basta che palle veloci volano a
parole c'erano fatto il convinto ha pure
lei
ora trovato grazie a dio grazie a dio
no dai non è se mi prende i ragazzi e
anche orecchiabile la canzone capito
cioè bella tra stesso fratello
[Musica]
[Applauso]
da betta balbuzie insomma la brodo no
non lo trovano tra le pistole nei
cassetti ma non il make up
poverini
[Musica]
buona la pasta così grosso va bene
completamente unexpected che si mangiano
suo gozzo però va bene pollice in su se
anche voi mangiate il suo gozzo ma
silvio comunque ragazzi e tra tutte
queste c'è una canzone che non è coreana
che avrei voluto ascoltare l'altra volta
ma non l'ho fatto merita quindi un
ascolto di ciò darebbe la conoscete
forse già però
[Musica]
ma con quanti pochi frame non lo sta
dicendo
[Musica]
dal voto di gennaio
io l'ho scelto
[Musica]
lo ascolta talmente tante volte che non
sarà anche qua a commentarla perché la
sua memoria sappiate che in genere in
italia
l'otto gennaio è festa nazionale perché
l'otto gennaio dalla porta si lascia
entrare ascanio sempre esce ma non mi
rode non è un hayter ascanio
[Musica]
già siamo partiti bene
per dire no i coreani non monetizzano
una sega comunque tutto non family
prende
grazie marco anno cazzo marco direi
ragazzi che con questo abbiamo concluso
il repertorio delle canzoni coreani
italianizzate almeno quelle degne di
nota secondo hanno accompagnato un po la
mia adolescenza della verità grazie alla
corea per averci lasciato dei
significati nelle loro canzoni perché
ovviamente sono rivolti a noi quindi
ragazzi brutta the cagate mangiate il
suo gozzo e lasciate entrare ascanio che
è molto importante vedere che possono
includere quei ragazzi spero che video
vi sia piaciuto come assessori processo
mi piace anche vari social capito sulla
descrizione tutti siete vi e nocivi amo
la vita
beh ragazzi
[Musica]